E aí
G1
eu sou uma apaixonada por ciência e
inovação o meu Fascínio começou Aos 9
anos quando na escola aprendi sobre um
uns seres vivos microscópicos ou
invisíveis chamados bactérias e depois
na esplanada do Café dos meus pais
percebi que todos são a minha volta
estava coberto por estes seres
invisíveis que se entregá dissima Com
estes bicharocos como é que podem ser
tão pequeninos e tão poderosos ao mesmo
tempo capazes de nos deixar doentes
fiquei agarrada a perguntas como estas E
aí decidi que queria e iria ser
cientista
nós estávamos na década de 90 numa vila
hoje a cidade de Valença lá bem no norte
de Portugal
eu e o meu contacto com a ciência não
era muito alto era baixo aliás sim eu
tinha um padrinho médico que mais do que
muita gente tem mas fora isso o meu
contacto com a ciência reduzia-se a
ciência que aprendia na escola e as
visitas escolares em conteúdos
relacionados com a ciência nos jornais
falava-se desporto e de política nada de
ciência a mesa as conversas com os meus
pais eram acerca dos novos restaurantes
que abriam de como cozinhar o melhor
bacalhau dos fornecedores ou dos
conflitos consiste em casa a televisão
era dominada pelo meu irmão mais velho
gostava de ver magaiver Michael night o
seu carro kit ou o Príncipe de bel-air
e as brincadeiras com as amigas Ângela
Maria João e Alexandra faziam-se com
Barbies de vez em quando lançar favão os
trabalhos da escola os relatórios e lá e
eu consultar assim ciclopédia os que
habitavam a sala lá de casa quando dizia
que queria ser cientista as reações eram
de estranhesa muita estranhesa caras
enroscados sobre olhos franzidos às
vezes eu até preferia não dizer nada
E era uma escolha invulgar fora daquilo
que as pessoas que me rodeavam conheciam
em sua defesa naquela altura em Portugal
quase que não se falava de ciência e a
imagem de cientista reduzia-se a imagem
do homem de meia-idade branco de cabelos
no ar
Eu sabia que a probabilidade de um filho
ou de uma filha seguir a carreira
profissional dos Pais é duas a três
vezes superior do que a probabilidade de
se filho dessa filha seguir uma carreira
profissional diferente por exemplo o
filho ou uma filha de uma mãe médica ou
de um pai médico têm uma maior
probabilidade de ser médico também um
médica Duque do que escolher outra
carreira profissional ser disruptivo nas
escolhas profissionais custa a que
ultrapassar barreiras familiares às
vezes culturais e sociais a que
ultrapassar estereótipos e preconceitos
a que trabalhar muito mais para se
atingir aquilo que se deseja comecei por
dizer que sou uma faxinada'
a ciência inovação foi esse facinho com
alguma teimosia coragem e resiliência a
mistura que fez com que a outra passasse
algumas Barreiras torneio cientista e
uma vez cientista fascina em outra vez
desta vez por um tópico apresentado por
uma amiga também ela cientista a Tatiana
sobre cooperação e Desenvolvimento
Social sobre diversidade e Equidade
sobre inclusão e sentimento de pertença
eu andei pela Suécia pelo pela Austrália
pelo Reino Unido pela Alemanha pela
França pela Suíça tudo a propósito a
minha carreira como instigador quando
vinha a Portugal e quando estava lá fora
senti-me como na crista da onda admirada
pela bravura ter ido lá para fora sentia
uma cientista internacional não sentia
uma Imigrante contudo por vezes
infelizmente poucas vezes ouvia
comentários como quer dizer então que
nem todos portugueses são Empregados de
limpeza
o ou frequentemente era interrompida nas
conversas com uma pergunta completamente
fora de contexto que era esse sotaque de
onde é que és
e por vezes sentir vergonha de não falar
um inglês tem sotaque outras vezes Tinha
simplesmente medo de falar
e por vezes sentia que vinha de um país
pequeno retrógrado de segunda liga
sentia que as vezes não tinha as mesmas
oportunidades que os nativos ou que nem
sempre era bem-vinda contudo fui lá para
fora e fui como adulta empoderada
informada com emprego fui numa situação
privilegiada Mas nem toda a gente que
vai lá para fora vai numa situação de
Privilégio passamos então pequenos
parentes para falar de migração Portugal
é tradicionalmente um país de muita
imigração uma pergunta para você sair em
casa respondam pondo a mão no ar por
favor põe a mão no ar aí em casa quem
tem familiares ou amigos a viver lá fora
em quase todos gostamos de ir e vamos
vamos solteiros Vamos com o namorado ou
com a namorada anos casados vamos
solteiros vamos com ensino superior ou
sem ensino superior vamos com trabalhos
em trabalho sabendo falar a língua do
país Para onde vamos ou não vamos à
procura da Aventura Vamos à procura de
uma recuperação e um desejo profissional
vamos em variados contextos
mas às vezes em alguns casos
em alguns povos também vão para fugir a
fome a guerra ou a falta de liberdade de
expressão um pequeno exercício agora de
imaginação neste caso vamos imaginar um
cenário hipotético estamos em casa é de
tarde temos sete anos é um dia
aparentemente normal e os nossos pais
dizem a conversar conosco dizem-nos que
temos que fazer as malas que vamos viver
para um país diferente que vamos afastar
daquilo que conhecemos dos amigos da
escola dos familiares mais próximos
Oi vó que vamos uns reagiram com
entusiasmo outros com medo podemos ir
para uma situação mais privilegiada ou
menos privilegiada podemos ir para um
contexto onde seremos a única pessoa de
pele branca ou de pele escura podemos ir
para um contexto onde falamos a língua
dominante ou não podemos ir viver por
uma zona mais segura de com canteiros de
flores as portas das casas e puxadores
com lustro ou podemos ir fazer o nas
menos seguras de casas Frias e rostos no
que toca a migração as forças motrizes
são várias e os sentimentos e atitudes
também mas uma coisa é certa que esta
seja uma criança ou um adulto há sempre
uma grande adaptação a fazer o meu
desejo
e numa perspectiva de celebrar a
diversidade e promover a inclusão EA
Equidade todos e cada um de nós sufoque
muito mais em tentar ir de encontro ao
outro e muito menos em tentar encaixar
Todos Nós já nos sentimos fora do lugar
na algumas situações todos de nós já
passamos horas a pensar no que vamos
dizer ou fazer para nos enquadrarmos
numa numa determinada situação para não
sermos postos de lado utilizando alguns
termos do inglês o que eu quero dizer
que estou a sugerir é que para caminhar
mos na direção de uma sociedade mais
justa e inclusiva
a cada um de nós diariamente se foque
mais em Reading Out para que haja menos
necessidade de fitness o sentimento de
pertença e a definição saudável da nossa
identidade são tão importantes como a
literacia e nas crianças são mesmo
fatores fundamentais para o sucesso
escolar da Europa a probabilidade de uma
criança migrante desistir da escola é
maior do que uma criança não Imigrante
também na Europa em média é duas vezes
mais provável uma criança migrante ter
baixo aproveitamento escolar do que uma
criança não migrante
E lá fora quando me junto outros colegas
investigadores
Oh e vamos a escolas falar do nosso
trabalho a crianças Imigrantes vamos
juntos em espírito missionário e
voluntário para transmitir conhecimentos
e abrir horizontes deixamos durante uma
tarde ou uma manhã os nossos
computadores as nossas fitas os nossos
artigos científicos ou as nossas
amostras ficam de repouso umas horas
o afinamos o nosso português italiano
espanhol francês alemão estoniano turco
grego enfim afinamos a nossa língua
língua materna e cheios de energia lá
vamos nós vamos ter com crianças
Imigrantes as escolas e fazemos
workshops de língua e ciência ao estilo
na eficientes nas escolas deparamos com
inúmeras realidades temos caso temos
muitos casos de sucesso temos também
muitos casos de crianças e adolescentes
que foram impactadas positivamente pelo
nosso trabalho recebemos afirmações como
este workshop foi bom porque me fez
pensar no que vou fazer quando acabar
secundário tenho 16 anos
eu não sabia que existiam pessoas como
eu nas universidades achava que a
universidade era apenas para os meus
colegas não migrantes sempre me sinto
como uma espécie rara Quando ando na rua
porque falo outra língua em casa com os
meus pais mas hoje percebi que há
imensas pessoas como eu enquanto falamos
do nosso trabalho com estas crianças na
nossa língua materna e na sua língua de
herança vemos os olhos a brilhar vemos
os sorrisos abrirem-se vemos a excitação
por aprender palavras novas palavras
como cérebro pulmão microscópio palavras
que eles conhecem na língua da escola
mas que desconhecem na língua de herança
ou na língua de casa porque porque na
correria do dia a dia o vocabulário aqui
As crianças estão expostas é vocabulário
relacionado com a gestão da casa e da
família coisas como vai lavar os dentes
vai fazer a cama já te disse que não
pode fazer isso
a e agora falando de novo vocabulário do
cérebro e de migração falemos também um
pouco de línguas de ser bilíngues e do
multilinguismo Os Desafios de educar uma
criança fala mais do que uma língua são
vários mas na maioria dos casos os
benefícios superam os desafios falamos
de benefícios a nível cognitivo
interpessoal e social benefícios a nível
da capacidade de memória e concentração
benefícios a nível da comunicação com os
outros tanto a nível pessoal como
profissional e benefícios a nível da
construção de sociedades mais tolerantes
e coisas
E aí
e estes benefícios são todos eles
importantes existem em qualquer pessoa
que falo mais do que me língua
independentemente de qual essa língua
for a sociedade com tudo associam o
valor diferente as diferentes línguas
por exemplo é diferente falar em casa o
inglês ou alemão ou falar em casa o
romeno ou uma tapa ao qual a sociedade
associa menos valor mas a nível dos
benefícios do multilinguismo não estão
sempre lá não interessa Qual a
identidade dessa língua tanto a nível da
criança como a nível do adulto ser
multilink é sempre um investimento e é
sempre uma mais-valia
e é parte da nossa identidade ajuda-nos
a manter um elo com as nossas famílias a
minha experiência e sensibilidade para
as questões da inclusão Equidade e
diversidade fez com começar a explorar
este mundo da educação nomeadamente da
educação das ciências e das línguas para
quebrar barreiras e estereótipos
e juntando cientistas e praticando
comunicação de ciência na nossa língua
materna vamos falar com crianças Falamos
pessoalmente por carta pela internet
através da Rádio ou através do livros
abrindo horizontes e mostrando duas
coisas primeiro que elas também podem
ser cientistas se assim o desejar e
segundo que a língua ou falar mais do
que uma língua é algo que devem
valorizar
eu acredito que devemos olhar para os
imigrantes com o mesmo respeito e
curiosidade que olhamos para os nativos
quando visitamos um país lá fora o seu
país
e o meu apelo é que sejamos todos mais
conscientes dos Desafios que cada um
poderá estar a enfrentar e dos riscos de
exclusão e desigualdade que surgem
devido a estereótipos ou por conceitos
ou generalizações terminam então com
duas sugestões duas sugestões de
cuidados muito simples que todos nós
diariamente podemos fazer primeiro irmos
mais de encontro ao outro fazendo mais
vídeos em alta segundo julgar menos as
pessoas pela diferença seja ela a
estatura a cor de pele o soltar o
vestuário termino dizendo que Se
pudermos pôr em prática estas duas
coisas muito simples estaremos a
construir uma sociedade mais inclusiva
e justa para que mais crianças de 9 anos
como eu consigam descobrir o que as
motiva E terá força e coragem de ir
atrás do seu sonho muito obrigado
[Música]